suite à vos duels répéter officiellement
interdite par la couronne il a été
décidé sur ordre du roi de france que
des sanctions exemplaires seraient
prises chevalier de brécé vous devez
fuir ce soir même l'exil est votre seule
échappatoire
je suis le chevalier de prese jeu fait
route vers la russie
je vais prêter mes services auprès du
tsar c'est auprès du roi de suède que je
la cherchais à son goût bienvenue en
russie chevalier il pas taillé
mobilisant 5000 hommes se préparent à
poltava contre les suédois
je vais donc retrouvé mon fils me
à la guerre tout étant donné selon les
règles la cavalerie mène la charge les
canonniers les grenadiers versent des
brèches et les fantassins se sacrifier
au japon
queval notifs nouzonnais nos rivalités
tout cela n'est plus rien dans la frange
de cette bataille